como nuestras hijas charlotte y las
futuras generaciones se suman a poder
ser escuchadas y sus votos van a contar
de buen mensaje las mujeres pues de que
el sufrimiento
harding oportunidades para lograr frans
hals significan stevens grandes logros
en tanto a nivel civil como en el
gobierno esta noche
vemos a héroes en nuestra tierra
pierce
he tenido el honor de conocer bastantes
héroes a través de todo este país con
los penn son una familia militar nuestro
hijo pertenece a los marines y mezclados
hijo herbie pertenece a la armada muchos
es una de nuestras iniciativas
calentar a las esposas de los militares
así como nuestra hija y nuestra era son
héroes también heroínas
salman historia de san jose escuchado
muchas historias de voluntariado y de
grandes contribuciones a las fuerzas
armadas en nuestras comunidades mis
pasos las esposas de los militares hacen
grandes movimientos cambian de trabajo
juanes ejercen de madres solteros
mientras exhiben orgullo fuerza y
determinación es antes de ser parte de
algo mucho más grande que ellas mismas a
todas las esposas de los militares
gracias a su presidente trompo y el
vicepresidente de tenis han apoyado las
fuerzas armadas de eeuu incluyendo las
familias en una escala significativa
mientras viajaban a nivel general del
país adoptando políticas
para permitir el empleo de esposas
militares el conoce a lisa brasil y
cameron cruz mismo paso estas esposas
del ejército decidieron empezar un
negocio llamado
böttcher de la segunda guerra mundial
hacen unas bolsas increíbles diseñados
por las esposas de militares y muchas de
estas esposas viven a nivel nacional y
ellos preparan su sección de la bolsa y
le envían al estado de carolina del
norte donde se ensambla el producto
final
dylan jan jönsson en montana es una
artista culinaria
que ha soñado con crear su restaurante
empezó su restaurante
así que sí abrió un segundo restaurante
en dover hámsters y como la segunda dama
la terapia para los veteranos
es bastante efectiva para el estrés
postraumático
el general cristo un veterano que conocí
en tampa fundar y que estuvo en irak y
en afganistán me dijo que nada lo había
apoyado más después de haber estado en
los marlins hasta aquí logró y aceptó ir
a la a tomar esta terapia y pues sea
terapia de artà
salvó su matrimonio y su vida sus crisis
siguió para establecer un lugar para
ayudar a otros veteranos ven y mandaron
en muchos de nuestros héroes veteranos
luchan mientras hace su transición hasta
la vida civil y en algunas ocasiones el
estrés es muy difícil para manejar solos
hace unas semanas tuve el honor de
hablar con algunos estadounidenses
increíbles paisas wine que respondieron
a la línea de
veteranos en crisis sin divulgan me
contó una historia que me impactó
jeanice eres signis me dijo que ha sido
el honor más grande de su vida hasta que
físicamente llegan a una clínica para
recibir la ayuda que necesitan y pueden
ayudarlos a los que necesitan en estos
tiempos difíciles todos vemos tantos
ejemplos de todos los estadounidenses
diariamente que ayudan a quienes los
necesitan aquellos martins en humildad
han considerado a otros más importantes
que a ellos mismos que hemos visto los
trabajadores de la salud profesores
están las personas en primera línea
los oficiales las personas que trabajan
en alimentos agricultores y tantos otros
héroes todos
hace 100 años las mujeres aseguraron su
voto
así que votemos poner o no haremos a
nuestra historia votemos al reciente
trump y el vicepresidente pensó por
otros cuatro años dios bendiga a
nuestros héroes y dios bendiga a estados
unidos